estamos observando la colección de
wallace en londres y esto es fragonard
su obra el columpio y lo primero que
noto es este pus de rosas de blancos
colores muy tiernos en el centro de la
pintura y esta mujer está sentada sobre
un columpio que sube y también me doy
cuenta que está sentada sobre un asiento
rojo terciopelo y dorado y está siendo
sostenida por una cuerda y veo el
fabuloso remolino en su sombrero también
vemos sus medias blancas y como en un
movimiento lanza la zapatilla al aire
ahora aquí tenemos tenemos la escena de
dos amantes porque claro lo que está
pasando es algo muy travieso aquí
tenemos a su amante escondido en los
arbustos mientras que está ella siendo
confiada por un caballero un poco mayor
que parece no tener idea de lo que está
pasando que el joven está escondido en
los arbustos y también podemos observar
dos cercas dos cercas que rodean esta
escultura en la izquierda entonces su
amado obviamente ha cruzado
a un área prohibida un área donde han
crecido grandes arbustos de rosas
silvestres y vemos también esta
escultura en la izquierda que muestra
una figura angelical que ha colocado un
dedo a la altura de su boca como
susurrando y mantén el secreto el
escenario se lleva a cabo no en un medio
salvaje sino en un jardín de algún
palacio y podemos ver arquitectura la
distancia bajo su brazo izquierdo es una
escultura donde han crecido de manera
excesiva arbustos es algo que está fuera
de control es la naturaleza en su forma
más enérgica fértil y abundante y nos
lleva a este escenario tan tan sensual
que también es un escenario como de
ensueño los árboles están llenos de
ramas es como en ocasiones lo que
representa lo maldito y casi como un
relámpago en el lienzo
esto expresa pasiones y es totalmente
totalmente apropiado aquí tenemos
también bajo la mujer dos esculturas que
parecen dos cupido son dos figuras que
están
jugueteando entre ellos están sobre algo
que para mí parece una colmena de abejas
quizás indicando las picaduras del amor
y algo que puede parecer desapercibido
es este pequeño perro que parece estar
ladrando y un perro es un símbolo de
fidelidad es un poco irónico en este
caso porque tal vez por eso el perro
está enojado parece como si el perro
está delatando a los amantes regalando
el secreto mientras que mientras que la
escultura de 6 esta es una obra de 1.767
estamos a unas décadas alejados aún de
la revolución francesa pero este es el
tipo de expresión de placer que que
caracteriza a la aristocracia a la clase
alta francesa también vemos que es este
tipo de pintura que será placentera a
los ojos de los pensadores de la
ilustración verán en la pintura del
rococó como llena
llena de virtudes una pintura heroica y
que apela a los más altos a las más
altas aspiraciones del ser humano y no
sólo aspiraciones básicas del hombre
la manera de pensar que llevará a la
revolución francesa en 1789